hi everyone I'm Emily and our dairy
parlor here at Farm Park and this is my
friend caramel caramel is one of our
dairy cows here specifically she's a
milking short horn and her job on the
farm is to make milk for us now before
caramel can make any milk she has to eat
a lot of food as you can see she's a
really big animal she weighs around
1,300 pounds or so her diet consists of
hay grass and grain all together she's
gonna eat around 100 pounds of food
every single day and she's going to
drink about 30 to 40 gallons of water
every day so she needs all that food and
water to make some for us but she will
only make milk if she's a girl and she's
a mom so when we say the word wow that's
actually what we mean a girl that's a
mom now caramel had her last calf in
February or her last baby so she's
making a lot of milk for us right now
and she keeps me right here on her udder
now we can either get that milk out
facing our hands or right using the
machine now I'm going to show you how to
use our pants so the first thing we do
is we want to put some teeth dip on her
this is basically just a sanitizer for
the cow
after that sits on there for a little
bit we can go ahead and wipe it off so
the way we milk is we take our pointer
finger and our thumb we wrap it right
around the base of her udder where it
meets her teeth squeeze those together
and then just squeeze our fingers around
a lot of people think that you have to
pull down to get the milk out but
actually we just squeeze our hand around
almost like a fist that sound you hear
right now is our milk machine rather
than trying to handle our cows twice a
day every day and suddenly use our milk
machine it's a lot faster and a lot
easier so before we put the machine on
it what we want to do is get a little
bit of milk out of each section up for
other so on the inside for utter is
divided up into four different sections
we just hand over to make sure that her
mouth looks alright and that her udder
feels okay
after that we put some pizzas on each
one of her teeth and we leave that on
for at least 30 seconds make sure sure
we kill any germs or bacteria so after
it's been 30 seconds we can go ahead and
wipe it keep it off each seat then we
can take our milk machine we call this
piece the claw we flip it over and once
we push in this button it turns on our
suction and that's what's gonna suck the
milk out of the cab
[Music]